esto es mío
[Música]
el que no quiera
no existe Colombia se llevó el premio el
abrazo al mejor largometraje por la
cinta Los reyes del mundo de Laura Mora
la película relata la historia de rap un
muchacho de la calle que emprende con
sus amigos un viaje de Medellín al bajo
cauca para recuperar las tierras que le
fueron robadas a su abuela una
desplazada del conflicto armado
para mí definitivamente el arte en
general El buen arte Debería ser
político y con eso no quiero decir
militante y a mí me atraviesa mucho la
obsesión sobre la justicia esos premios
son una posibilidad de que se vea la
película de que la película pueda viajar
más y pueda tener un diálogo más amplio
con el público en el mundo
estamos muy emocionados pero yo todavía
no me lo creo mucho extorsión secuestro
robo de material clasificado viendo
laburones
el premio del Jurado fue para una
comedia negra Argentina punto rojo de
nicanor loretti quien hizo reír al
público con esta cinta que mezcla
Thriller mucha creatividad visual y
Pasión por el fútbol
la verdad que Fue increíble verla con el
público de biarritz porque es un gran
público y mucha gente va a ver todas las
películas una sala enorme siendo una
película subtitulada de humor donde hay
humor negro y la reacción las risas del
público con el humor fue muy
gratificante la verdad
el Jurado presidido por el director
francés Enrique plástico se felicitó por
la fuerza del cine latinoamericano
lo que más nos emocionó a todos en el
Jurado es ese espíritu desesperado al
mismo tiempo libre del cine en
latinoamericano Vimos a una América
Latina que sigue estando conmocionada y
al mismo tiempo que es súper potente
[Música]